I don't like guns at all I don't have a
negative theme of guns
I do have negative opinions about people
I've been invited to a gun range before
with friends and I've said no and have
just sat in the car outside of the gun
range while they shotgun I'm an Eagle
Scout I was raised in the south I've
shot a lot of guns 22 rifle ten gauge
shotgun 12-gauge shotgun Desert Eagle
and another type of handgun that I don't
remember who owns my bachelor party
what I shot an arrow once I questioned
why as a society we consider guns
masculine it's like a James Bond thing
and he's like a cool sexy guy and I'm a
cool sexy guy they keep talking about
James Bond people not shut up about
Texas we dressed like James Bond it's
not real somehow these are
military-grade weapons whose only
purpose is to kill people to kill a lot
of people very fast very effectively
when you grew up around guns you know
how to handle them properly you should
be able to go to a gun range and fire
military-grade weapons I'm gonna go into
this fresh thinking what is the feeling
that I'm gonna get from it because maybe
there is something to like masculine
eating guns if I get to wear a tuxedo
and shoot guns I'm excited
you could die
wait I'll look it up here for you okay
close it and I'm ready this is live guys
the first bullet went off in that jump
that was not ready for it there was no
like ready set go honey here goes
nothing Jesus Christ
salt rifles are actually easier to shoot
than handguns there's hardly any kick
because it goes so fast it's easy to
forget while you're there that the
purpose of these guns is to kill people
and each time you're pulling the trigger
that's another life you could be taking
it gives you this real adrenaline that
took me hours to come down from I think
my body went on a high yeah and I just
completely turned into this like very
primitive basic creature when you just
repeat shoot like that
you're almost afraid of yourself me
taking the safety off
[Music]
does my cheekbone really have to be that
close to the ground it's not gonna hurt
my feet move your body forward okay we
came like an adult toy guns are not toys
now that I've done it I get it it's like
I'm turning it to an animal I would try
to shoot this guy in the nuts who does
that I go then how many times I'm
shooting this and all I could think of
all I was shooting is oh man I hope I'm
out of bullets
[Music]
for the biggest revolver a virtually
made we were just the closest to the red
dot will not have to pay for dinner it's
like playing around the golf with
weapons exactly you see all the recoil
is too much for you let it go over your
head do not fight it because it will
come back though you can punch yourself
in the face yeah don't do that
Wow it is heavy who do you think will be
the worst from what you see that was
terrifying
Keith Winn I'm really glad I did it
I've not done it so many times because I
was afraid but I face my fear and I
think it's totally fine to shoot any
kind of gun in a gun range because
that's the place you go you play golf on
a golf course you shoot guns in a gun
range first thing I said when I held the
gun was I turned in that I said take a
photo of me and the hole I can think of
is I'm desperately trying to compensate
for something I get it
I I now get it I didn't get it and now I
get it
guns are easy fun it changed me I don't
think that I'm as pro-gun as I used to
be in terms of actually feeling more
manly from shooting a gun I don't think
I'm more of a man the experience didn't
turn us into men it turned us into boys
I might have kids one day
there's no way that my kids are
responsible gun owners an accident is
bound to happen the men were the people
at the gun range who really knew what
they were doing I respect that
I guess my takeaway today is that the
whole thing is a little more complicated
I see why people like you I
it doesn't necessarily change the way I
think but it does shade it in a little
bit for the record for me personally
eating kids still more of them and
there's quite a kick